my name aggression crisis might be
brewing for House Speaker Paul Ryan and
his leadership team we told you last
night that the house is just five GOP
votes away from bringing several
different daca bills to the floor in a
tactic to go around house leadership GOP
leaders fear the effort could cost the
party control of the house in the
midterm elections here to debate it
Republican Jeff Denham from California
who supports the maneuver and Republican
Sean Duffy from Wisconsin who opposes it
all right guys you gotta explain where I
get into all the parliamentary tricks
queen of the hill and in discharge
petition will lose a whole audience so
congressman Denham you are really in
favor of turning the House floor over to
Nancy Pelosi to run this debate why no
not at all I expect to have a full
debate in front of the American public
do exactly what Paul Ryan said when he
took the speakership over the Democrats
no not at all the Speaker the discharge
petition that's the maneuver isn't it
yes which we have a Republican majority
we control all of the rules the leader
controls the floor debate Paul Ryan has
his own bill the president has a bill
Goodlatte has a bill I mean yes the
Democrats get a bill too but ultimately
we're gonna do what the president is
asking for and give him border security
because we cannot wait any longer you
know look every year that goes by
another half a million people come
across our southern border so the eight
years that Sean and I have been in
office together that's four million
people from doing nothing it is time to
act in this president sounds fantastic
this is practically he's practically
building the wall I'm selves going on I
think we want to get to the same spot I
don't I don't like the tactic Jeff knows
that I don't think that discharge
petition is the way to go it does I
think turn the floor over to a what's
called queen of the hill you put out
four bills the one that gets to 18 which
is a majority is the one that passes
here's the deal we have a wide agreement
on Trump's four pillars that'll pass so
so Jeff will vote for that their freedom
caucus will vote for that all we need is
leadership to put the trump bill up in
the house it'll pass for you you two
guys smart guys
the Goodlatte bill is a right way to go
I know you're my central d'italia
worried about the farmers worried about
those workers coming in get
stop this chain migration that is the
mass multiplier of immigration into the
United States with distant relatives
hopscotching into the country without
merit without basis of merit chain
migration gotta build the wall we got to
reform the asylum process all that has
to be done and we got to get rid of the
visa lottery oh that's that's got to be
done that's all in the Goodlatte bill
why the heck why we don't work why don't
we have it for bills you don't use
before bill you don't have you don't
have we don't have the votes for a good
lap I would that's despicable it is but
here's the deal Donald Trump run and
said I said listen I want to build a
wall all those other things have come in
on the backside so let's come together
put twenty five billion dollars in let's
build the wall and make some other
tweaks to again stop chain migration
it's not the Visa Lottery will deal with
Daka but that's the package that the
president wants it's very generous to
the daca kids
but it also gives us border security and
we could all vote for it I don't know
what's gonna happen in the Senate I
can't be over there I can't support the
Goodlatte bill because so many people
talk about extending amnesty I did not
support President Obama's executive
order I thought that was
unconstitutional and I felt that
Congress needs to do its job and
actually do real real reform and just
doing an extension of Obama's policy
three years at a time doesn't make any
sense look if we're gonna do this we
need to make sure that we fixed the wall
and fix some of these problems but also
have a permanent fix
I want to build the wall absolutely I do
want to build the whole wall that just
my source so the only thing only problem
you have with Goodlatte is the amnesty
for what ends up being 800,000 I think
right correct yeah yeah it is it is an
extension of President Obama's executive
order rather than dealing with this as
the present as the president has asked a
chain migration Visa Lottery and chain
migration you immediately change that
the game with immigrants but he did
change the dynamic for these kids that
have gone to our high schools and did it
and an executive order
unconstitutionally if we're going to fix
this because it's now an American
problem because both presidents of both
parties have kicked this can down the
road divide the party you know this will
divide the party before the midterm
election this is what the president's
asking for he wants the end of chain
migration and he wants the wall built
and he wants to end a versatile
versatile lot every other day that
something about this the two weeks ago
he said specifically if we do not have
this done before the CR then he did not
want to see you CR he once I make sure
that we actually have borders there's a
problem with a docket kids if you don't
end keen migration all of a sudden the
the kids of the parents who brought them
in illegally all of a sudden get legal
parents are all staying we actually have
to fix that part of it when we deal with
daca as well but the key here is Donald
Trump ran in a wall let's build it 25
billion I think Donald Trump did not win
on giving amnesty to the daca kids he
won on border security building the wall
and even Californians majority want
deportations to go on that Berkeley poll
that came out the other day is is
devastating 59% once somewhat important
or very important to start deporting
these people but the president's also
put the Democrats on notice on this
issue as well the Democrats have had had
forty two billion in out of the Senate
and out of every Democrat in the house I
think it's time to put them to the test
on this issue as well we want to deal
with this issue as Republicans we don't
to turn this over to Nancy Pelosi if
there's I don't think we're losing the
house but if we did she'll deal with it
let's deal with it as Republicans and a
family solution and and again I don't
think this is the right process I think
we should outside of turning the Ford
Nancy speaking speaking a queen of the
hill kings of the hill guys great to
have you on